that's the crazy thing is they're G's
about they're like all right this is
sick yeah this is this is what he made
we're gonna like kill it they're super
chill so like he just sends us the
Mortal Kombat theme
we trust him creatively we trust him
it's working it's working
[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys
where we are currently off of the record
totally so officials
we're gonna get a music copyright for
that right now you really just gonna
take it what song is that two seconds in
Sandstorm it's called I can't stop it
[Laughter]
uh we are now demonetized that being
said we're gonna do part two of a let's
check in and catch up again the first
quarter of the year is now done we
didn't get a chance to hear from some of
our other brothers here Mr Nicholas Mr
Ryan email Mr Jitsu Kawa but Nicholas
has like he's a puppy daddy he's okay oh
yeah you got dogs now you're fine he's
been I got two pups dude what you've
been up to how's 2023 treating him with
the first three months it's been really
good it's been it's been really busy
almost too busy but that sounds good
yeah no it's good your business yeah
business has been raise your rate how
much is it gonna take for you to abandon
us what do you mean everyone's got a
price honestly the way I look at it your
business is so good I'll say the way I
look at it is we film four days out the
month like I can make time for that but
what if it's in Vegas yeah but we
dedicate so much extra time and energy
and love to making sure like amazing you
guys do I just show up dude I'm just
here you guys are the hosts and you're
here to ask annoying questions as well
yeah I'm here to [__] make you guys
life miserable I ask stupid questions
that doesn't even matter what city is
this in
do you think this guy wears turtlenecks
or no
um yeah but but it's good it's been
really busy
um like your in-person stuff or your
online stuff both both has been really
busy uh and then now we have two we have
two dogs so we have two pups we have two
little pugs are you keeping them yeah
we're keeping them whoa and they're
they're at our house right now my wife
just texted me she says
because she's a therapist and she does
her uh calls at home and she goes the
dogs are just crying in the in the
living room right now what are you gonna
do when they [__] each other so that's
the thing we're gonna have to separate
them we're gonna figure out yeah we're
gonna figure out a way so they don't
mate with each other you're not gonna
like neuter them or spay them we're
going to but like I'm sure there's going
to be uh a really fine window where I
have to like are you are you going to or
are you full of [__] and you're actually
doing a puppy Farm
no dude I don't think I can do a puppy
Farm I don't think I have the heart and
I can't do it you don't think so what do
you the puppies that we had we even
everybody's got a price
that's true 11 hundo a pup but isn't
that bad for the dogs if the brother and
sister are having sex with each other I
thought that's how they made purebreds
you can't really tell that they're
inbred until yes later and pugs look
Downs already like they're already down
to doggies isn't that what they say
about purebreds they're just all like
all productive let's just start walking
in the walls and [__] that's I mean ah
man I think I got an inbred one my my
dogs they're fun though they're they're
they smell like fresh pups I'll pick
them up before I go to work and I'll
just
like a baby like a you know like a baby
smell this is a weird conversation
[Laughter]
you're biting me smelling kids yeah
how's the marriage
[Laughter]
honestly the one thing she's like she's
probably uh getting annoyed about is me
not being home as much because I'm just
like not home you're so busy yeah do you
blame JK
no but it contributes well what do you
what do you do that makes you so busy
yeah you don't even hang out with them
I'm at the gym all the time dude pumping
weight what times
I'm Gonna Leave the household time you
come back uh depending on the day I'll
leave at like 6 a.m or earlier damn but
then sometimes it's like seven or I'll
wake up earlier to hang out with the
pups for a little bit and then like you
know I'll be gone and then I'll be I
live really close to the gym so that's
convenient but don't you so you don't
pop back in or yeah but sometimes it's
like even though it's like a five minute
drive from the gym like just stay I need
to stay at the gym because I'll have
other clients is it hurting your love
life to choose money over your love no
but I tell her I'm like we trying to
we're trying to make money they're
trying to buy a house yeah we're trying
to stack we're trying to are you really
trying to buy a house eventually yeah
definitely we'll see if I can afford it
unless we'll get scratches lottery
tickets that's what I've been that's
what I've been uh buying too on top of
working a bunch so yeah just been doing
all that stuff and I just feel like
there's not enough hours in the day to
get stuff done but that's enough of my
boring story what's up with you no
that's good no thanks for opening up
dude you wake up at six a.m wow we love
so much hey honestly yeah we know you
like those [__] Snippets
honestly I'm [__] boring [__] all I
do I'm at the gym it's not boring but
what are you excited about in your life
yeah I'm excited about work I'm and that
sounds bad too but I'm really excited
about work when you say work that mainly
comprises of like training your clients
yeah working with clients you know
getting some new prospects seeing how we
could how's my song doing is he killing
it Mike song's the man dude I'd be
seeing him in the videos dude Mike is
he's great he's he has a he's a good
spunky attitude and sometimes yeah he's
spunky dude does he have a second stripe
yeah no but like I'll hear him
struggling I'll hear him [__] live
like he's like energy trying to [__]
do Jitsu so that's fun I want to be your
guys's punching bag every time I go to
Lionheart Jutsu Academy just come train
it's a good vibe it's a great Vibe I
like I like them a lot how many of your
clients are like Jiu Jitsu based or uh
like weight loss based like most of my
clients are like weight loss or just
trying to get in hell like healthy you
know what I mean yeah or just trying to
help that Davidson has been weight
training with you more yeah he's been
lifting with us with all the me and all
the trainers at the gym so you guys have
a lifting time we have a little group
yeah
because every time David through
sometimes we just end up not working out
have a conversation and before you know
we're at a restaurant no and I'm like
what
usually that's what happens with David
but we've been really good about it
because he's he I think he really wants
to start like you know getting in better
shape and after he lost all that weight
he wouldn't he name drops in the
restaurant everyone's mouth starts
salivating nah because most of the
people that he's working out with are
all trainers there so we're like no no
you got to work out oh they're like yeah
we all are all right so it's like it's a
good environment for him I think but
it's fun it's fun dude I go right with
that guy we're supposed to go right and
then we are I'm like how do we end up in
a restaurant like we're in right here
dude we brought our laptops for four
hours just bullshitting then we go back
to his place we write for like 35
minutes and then he he over explains why
it was good that we didn't write because
now we'll be even more ready for next
time
when and then when I'm on my way he's
like hey meet me at this restaurant okay
you know what's funny David David
recently has been on a kick about
um baking cheesecakes what he can't so
this dude can't come to the gym I mean
he's like hey uh I made a bunch of
cheesecakes I'll be right over at the
gym are you gonna be at the gym he comes
by and he just has a whole platter of
cheesecakes for us and he just drops it
off at the gym he's just trying to find
equilibrium with the people he hangs out
with so like everybody gets a little
fatter he loses a little weight yeah it
just kind of combines I don't know but
it was delicious it was a great
cheesecake it's a Korean sabotage this
is what it's like working out with David
you know or just being in a gym the gym
is fun it's hard it's it's it's like uh
it's fun it's like being here but all
day with weights around so that makes
sense that's very different why are you
guys all looking at me like I'm a lion
how's your mental health huh how's your
mental health it's good are you that
happy place is yeah
100 yeah 2023 is definitely way better
than the last couple years for sure but
yeah it's been good I really can't
complain dude I now yeah now you guys
are laughing now it makes me feel
insecure that's what's happening no this
is cool no no
is this good content
I think that's I think that's what we're
looking at you about yeah
dude yeah I'm sorry I got nothing for
you guys the puppies honestly the
puppies are the highlights
hot the puppies are the highlights dude
they're [__] and pissing everywhere
you promise me that when you do the long
form thing with my anime that you talk
about your clients the whole time I
probably will unfortunately that's
that's just that's what it is okay
unfortunate have you ever had to like
give up a client to be like yo you're
not losing weight dude because you're
too fat get out of here it's not like
that it's more of like we don't really
like I don't say Vibe but it's because
you don't want them to keep paid if
they're not like progressing yeah that's
definitely been a conversation I've had
it with a couple people but sometimes
it's like uh yeah it's just it's it's
just part of the biz yeah forget your
clients what about your personal goals
remember you said you were gonna like
start fighting again I never said that
well I'm not fighting no what about jits
you're gonna take just more serious or
something you did a tournament though
yeah yeah
and then you're talking about like maybe
getting back into it like yeah but then
now it's just like I'm just I have no
time I'm literally too big I'm too busy
with but do you want to not really are
you like frustrated that you don't have
the time or you're just good I'm kind of
okay cool we'll see how that changes in
a couple months but as of now it's like
um yeah it just the business right now
what was it was it like I miss a
competitive thing and now you got it out
of your system kinda I think I'm kind of
like that I think like every now and
then I'll be like do a competition and
then I'll be like yeah I'm good
um but at the same time I think what
really
motivates me and drives me is to like
work on the business a little bit so
just um doing more of the work I guess
is your business like your training or
is it uh because I know you have a
partner Marlin do you guys work on
something together or is it like two
businesses that like to work together or
like yeah definitely so it'll be my
clients the online side and the in
person and then Marlin is the buddy of
mine that we've been working making
videos together and then it just works
for for all of us I don't work on
programs as well too but that's pretty
much it once again really fun content
dude so fun to talk about Ryan what
about you
[Laughter]
no but honestly like that's that's I'm
in the gym all day you know like do you
think since I said that five times do
you think since you already expressed
that side of your like like you
accomplished doing fights professionally
or whatever that now you want to switch
into like the business side because you
haven't really done that like are you
like
doing something different and new for
yourself yeah for the most yeah I think
so and that that's more fun for you yeah
well actually I think it's more about
the gym the location that we have like
it's just I think
the energy in there the vibe in there
it's actually having something that we
built that's pretty cool and the
community that we've built in there is
really great and I feel all the people
that are around it they can kind of feel
it too so you're passionate about the
the the community there that's what it
is that helps out a lot it helps out a
lot and you're also making money
together like that's that's what's fun
yeah I have a like-minded group of guys
that want to like you know do more do
better you know that's about it
it takes six it takes a village to
interview Nick
what do you have any questions Steve
you're pretty great you've been great
actually
we're being the the game up a little bit
because that's my favorite thing is just
how he answers and his toad is just like
he hates his own answer
my favorite bit about you I'm rushing to
get over it my favorite bit about you is
why the [__] are you on YouTube and it
and it always hits pretty hard yeah
because it's like I was thinking about
this the other day when I was washing
the dishes actually yeah and I was
thinking this is good content now yeah
and I was thinking about Steve going
like well why are you on YouTube and I
was like
because Barton Joe asked me
and I'll go and I'm like and I'm like is
that the only reason why I like I show
up and it's kind of one of the only
reasons why picture you're asking me the
guy on the edge of a building tell me
something to make me not want to jump
man and Nick goes I don't even know this
is [__]
[Laughter]
okay dude honestly I might be like well
if if you feel like this is what's right
with me because you're like sucks too
yeah I got pugs
[Laughter]
they smell like uh smell like little
kids honestly me picking up and just
feeling their skin on my cheek is one of
the best it is dude it really is nothing
beats it it's nothing beats it it's and
honestly for me I guess I'm lame and
stupid and whatever but it's like it's
the little things in life that get to be
going dude just picking up the pups dude
feeling two puppies by your face it
cures depression dude it honestly does
don't look him like the Anthony well
dude I love this concept and you know
also too I'm allergic to the dogs I'm
allergic to what the [__] yeah but it's
fine
his eyes all swollen I get all red I get
all itchy the garden can't breathe
through his nose
just like risky Behavior don't close up
starts turning on all the gas
but yeah just dealing with puppies and
stuff at home yeah that's it all right
this is boring how is that what are you
doing we're gonna do that 13 minutes
earlier
I've been a chance like the the UCLA
women's gymnastics season is about to
end and uh because I I do their floor
exercises he does all the mixes oh
really yeah he choreographs for them the
floor yeah yeah oh you mixed her music
yeah I do I do their whole like track
stuff so when they're like flip like
that it's like you made that song yeah
they're a whole like uh program so like
uh if you guys
check any of that stuff out it's it's
doing really well are you DJing like are
you curating or are you doing it from
scratch you're talking about like
content on YouTubes or like
they're competitive like mixes doing
well aware though is what I'm saying oh
just like online yeah like on YouTube
Instagram like it got it got reposted by
SportsCenter a bunch which is like I've
always wanted to see something I did end
up on SportsCenter so like in a way I'm
like oh that's pretty cool but uh yeah
like you know like uh so kind of like
when we did Quest Cruise shows the style
of mixes that we would have was stuff
that I would make and then people would
see that and go oh I want that for my
ice skating show I want that for my
theater show they want that same style
um and then that's kind of how it led to
me doing how do people find you how do
they even know like do they ask like off
stage like who made the yeah that that
time uh that this particular connection
came from I was doing mixes for like
Nike headquarters for like their uh
product their product showcases and then
um because every time they release new
Nike products they have to show it to
the shareholders first and they have to
show them with the performance they
don't just go like here's a shirt you
have to like do a show yeah and then I
was doing the music for those and then
uh employee there uh was like oh I have
a friend that does UCLA gymnastics needs
the same exact thing oh cool and then it
just connected that way how much how
many other [__] random crazy gigs do
you have there's in that world there's
quite a bit of weird stuff like that
Ryan is a renaissance man so he probably
has like 18 other businesses
JK that's why he's worth 25 million
gymnastics sound mixing show he's like I
designed all the maps for GTA for the
last six years
what other stuff what other stuff do you
do I mean music-wise there's there's
like a lot of odd jobs like that because
it's all just freelance so like there's
how do you get the gigs it's just Word
of Mouth like even the you're like you
know how to play stuff enough like there
was this there was this Disney movie on
Netflix called work it it's like a dance
film and I soundtracked most of that
what yeah but it's like but that it's
very specific it's like very Niche it's
like hey we need to use this song but we
need it to match in this way oh so it's
a very like not everybody would know how
to do that and do it well yeah but
that's like a Tupac song but Bossa Nova
style it's like backwards it's like when
uh when I was doing Bossa Nova song
Tupac style yeah like for the Olympic
skaters it's a backwards thing where
like I was soundtracking their thing but
for them it's like as they practice
their Olympic piece through the through
the year they get faster and faster at
certain points because they're getting
better so rather than them matching the
music you have to match their
performance because it's it's in their
muscle memory so like I have to watch
their practice footage like every week
and go okay now this needs to be slower
now this thing will be faster because
they can't they can't afford to change
what they're doing for the pain in the
[__] ass yeah are you doing this for
some parts yeah for some parts slow down
dude yeah that's that's another thing
too is like like it's like when uh when
you do remixes for for film or TV like
there are certain instruments that
you're not gonna have on hand like you
you need to isolate the piano so you
have to play it yourself like stuff like
that like even for the gymnastic stuff
there's some instruments that uh like if
they're they give me five songs they go
okay here this is Jordan Childs her
theme of her floor exercises this here's
the six songs we want to use whatever
order you think is good and then chain
it all together and then make time for
the parts where she stops make time for
the parts where she's running to do the
round off like those all have to be
soundtrack so that uh you get the
maximum score so that everybody goes oh
I know that I should cheer here and that
this the power is strong here it's a
very formulaic thing where it's like
it's never just as simple as like a song
plays yeah you see the other like uh the
other gymnasts from other like states
and their [__] is just like one song and
you can see the different it's why like
nobody rolls you know but you have to
kind
of like to go like oh it's rareing up
for this part and then uh it's very
weird where like if too much is
happening and the gymnast is not hitting
it with any movement then it looks bad
it looks like why why is there so much
musical cues but no one's hitting
anything so you have to like know that
okay here she needs time to rest for
this big combinations coming up it's
super as boring as Nick should but you
know that doesn't know that's way cooler
honestly in my head while you're
explaining that I was like oh that's how
you talk because you also accept clients
zero times yeah you didn't just say like
well I trained I train them
and you gave like a reason why it's
interesting yeah for the UCLA uh that's
like my third year doing it and then um
like Jordan Childs is one of the people
that's like super killing it and and uh
the when you look at UCLA's gymnastics
performances for the women's it's night
and day difference from every other uh
gymnast performance in like the whole uh
pac-10 or whatever the NCAA because they
think about the music and everything the
performance yeah their themes are just
like and the people that choreographed
their actual thing are like dancers too
so they like so like the musicality the
storytelling like understanding the
audience's ride and all that stuff it's
the kind of [__] that like we really
like so I like working with them and
they make it so easy they're dope they
literally just do that they just send me
a bunch of songs and go here's the stuff
she likes make a thing that's it and
they don't really like if they trust
like what I make they're not very like
oh can we do this can we do that they're
just super cool about like that's your
thing and we want yours the athletes
never go like oh but I like this part of
I'm a Barbie girl
that's the crazy thing is they're G's
about it they're like all right this is
sick yeah this is this is what he made
we're gonna like kill it they're super
chill so like he just sends us the
Mortal Kombat theme
we trust him creatively we
but that's my freelance work is very
like random like that yeah it could be
anything music-wise I'm surprised you
don't be trolling it all the time dude
sometimes I put some funny not in theirs
but when I some jobs I'll put funny [__]
like I'll just hide stupid stuff do you
do other random [__] too like maybe like
cut someone's hair or like I feel like
all your [__] is so crazy yeah yeah you
ever throw some Final Fantasy in there I
put uh I put a lot of
I put a lot of Smash Brothers sound
effects that's sick that like most
people wouldn't know but like it just
sounds so good that it's like oh it just
works but I think if you're like a gamer
and you're watching the floor exercises
you're gonna go away like what sound
effects
I've got that [__] that's the only sound
you're gonna hear if you play me a Smash
Bro
S I played nest and I play dirty no but
I do I do use ness's baseball bat sound
the home run but because yeah the Home
Run bad such a great sound I put that in
there a lot uh and then I put something
from uh from Skyrim like where you do
the foosro dot like oh yeah those are
that's a great sound yeah there's like
little things in there but to the
average person you wouldn't know I love
I love just like the most interesting
man in the world going right after a
Nick Story too though it's the contrast
is so good it's almost like a UCLA mix
you know what I mean how it rides yeah
his video was poetic for that reason
yeah that's why Ryan's the man that's
very it's a super tiny Niche like thing
I think it's like what BART likes it's
like Stark cold so that so that nobody
watches the next part of the video Yeah
is this good content and then boom yeah
yeah that's good content like when
somebody says like is this good content
and then makes the audience go yeah
maybe why should I watch it maybe I'll
move on a little yeah